[Музика]
привіт всім мене звати Наталія
юшко пора урок англійської давайте почнемо
тому сьогодні останній урок у нашій
темі транспорт давайте перевіримо все,
що ми навчилися давайте
спочатку почнемо давайте перевіримо домашнє завдання минулого разу я
попросив вас знайти п'ять помилок у
тексті, тож давайте розглянемо одну за одною,
тож перша з них, яку ви коли-небудь бачили
гру в крикет, є помилка так
добре зроблено, тому ми не можемо використовувати дієслово так,
тому що це минуле просте і  тут у
нас є теперішній досконалий час, тож
правильною відповіддю буде гарна сцена,
давайте йти далі багато людей скажи
мені, що це справді нудно, скажи мені,
чи це правильно, ні, це знову не так
теперішній досконалий час, яке слово нам
використовувати сказав  Браво, давайте йти далі, але я
повністю не згоден, тому наступне речення, яке
я ще повернувся з гри між
Англією та Індією, так що я все ще повернувся
, це нормально, ні, це не так правильний
прислівник буде вже я
вже повернувся або  щойно повернулися
це також можливо, давайте перейдемо до ще
однієї помилки, тож давайте подивимося на це насправді
ми вже купили квитки на завтра
чи все гаразд ми вже до побачення зараз
це
не знову відмінок минулого для
теперішнього ідеального обороту для світу на
є обидва  правильно, і адже гра
ще не закінчена, яка помилка
тут ніколи не добре, тому нам потрібно використовувати
ще, і правильний буде після того,
як гра ще не закінчена, тому п'ять
помилок тут я  впевнений, що ви
знайшли їх усі, тож давайте продовжимо
розглянути дієслова транспортний засіб
швидко запам'ятайте якомога більше або
перегляньте їх один два три чотири п'ять без
зображення добре, тому є завдання для вас,
я збираюся поставити букву  на дошці,
і ми проведемо мозковий штурм слова,
які починаються з тієї ж букви, і
ми будемо використовувати транспортні засоби, тож
давайте почнемо, давайте почнемо з, давайте подивимося
, давайте подивимося, які транспортні засоби
починаються з тієї ж букви  перший
, який спадає на
думку  я це машина, давайте поїдемо автомобіль, який ще
тренер, тож ти візьми свій блокнот і
напиши зі мною, якщо у тебе є різні
слова,
тоді ми разом знайдемо та перевіримо,
щоб наступний, щоб почати,
побачити канатну дорогу що-небудь інше, так автомобіль, автобус,
фунікулер, що  ще ми говорили про
Єгипет, пам’ятайте, тому можливим
транспортним засобом для Єгипту може бути верблюд,
напевно, ви знаєте свої слова, і ви
можете закінчити павука Грема, давайте
йти іншою літерою, давайте йти з T,
тому транспортні засоби почніть з T
для  мені перше слово таксі що ще
поїзд улюблене слово одного з наших
студентів трамвай що ще дуже популярне у
всіх великих містах тролейбус будь-що інше
хмм
трамвай таксі поїзд тролейбус вантажівка звичайно
і пахне, це починається на Т, якщо у вас
є більше слів, закінчіть  павук Грем,
давайте з іншою літерою
, буде М, а для мене
мотоцикл
мотоцикл також можливий, тож давайте
запишемо, що ще у нас є Метро,
'ятайте добре, якщо у вас є щось  g
інакше просто додайте їх до своєї землі Spyder за
допомогою em
давайте почнемо з s давайте переглянемо,
так що шкільний автобус, що ще дуже популярно в
Італії, пам'ятайте скутер, чого ще ми
не бачимо, це зазвичай під водою так
підводний човен, і якщо він знає, що  почніть з
нас, хм, я не пам'ятаю, чи пам'ятаєте ви,
запишіть слова, а закінчимо
на H, тому не так багато слів починаються з віку,
якщо ми говоримо про транспортні засоби, але
давайте спробуємо перше слово, яке спадає
мені на думку, вертоліт
вертоліт що  інакше, хм,
дошка, яку можна використовувати як будинок, тому
ми називаємо її будинком для будинку, тому ми
переглянули майже всі слова, тому в мене є
літера B, я не збираюся викладати її на
дошку, але швидко продумаю слова,
які починаються на B  борт
велосипед велосипед що ще
автобус будь-що інше швидко запишіть слово
і давайте ще раз подивимося на
слова вибачте, у
нас є поїзд поліцейський автомобіль, верблюд,
таксі, літак, як ви бачите, у нас багато
букв, тому вдома після уроку ви
можете продовжити  практика  ви просто візьміть одну
літеру і напишіть слова, які починаються
на ту саму букву, це дуже гарна
редакція, особливо перед тестом, тож
давайте перейдемо, подивіться, у нас є три
групи слів привод літаю правильно і у нас
є засоби пересування велосипед автобус
автомобіль  трамвай мотоцикл потім таксі гелікоптер
скутер і літак що тут нове слово
так коли, тому ми не використовували його раніше,
тоді це велика машина і вона виглядає
як мікроавтобус, тож давайте подивимося на ці
три групи,
що ми можемо їздити на чому  ми можемо літати ось
що ми можемо написати давайте почнемо з приводу чи
можемо ми водити велосипед хм, на жаль,
ми їздимо на велосипеді, тому ми можемо їздити на
автобусі ми можемо керувати автомобілем ми можемо водити
таксі та фургон, тому давайте разом перевіримо
подивіться автобус автомобіль trum  фургон і таксі, і
я прошу вас повторити за мною в
реченні я можу керувати автобусом повторює я
можу керувати автомобілем я можу керувати фургоном
молодці давайте рухаємося далі з другою групою
літаємо
що ми можемо літати чи можемо ми літати на скутері
мабуть не так гелікоптер який  інакше
добре зроблений літак, щоб ви могли сказати, що я можу літати
на вертольоті, або ми можемо літати на вертольоті,
і ми можемо керувати літаком, якщо ви не можете, що
ви скажете, я не можу літати на вертольоті або
літак молодець третя категорія  це
легко правильно, так що ми їздимо на велосипеді,
мотоциклі та скутері, тепер давайте
скажемо, що ви можете їздити або літати,
а що ви не можете, наприклад для мене я
можу керувати машиною, таксі та фургоном,
але я можу  не керуй гелікоптером чи літаком
одночасно я можу їздити на велосипеді,
але я не можу написати мотоцикл або
скутер, а ти скажи, що ваше речення
може чи не можна добре виконано, давайте рухатися далі може,
щоб ви могли сказати, що я  я можу і я не можу, і у мене
є для вас два маркера: червоний
із «Я не можу» і синій із «Я можу»,
тому, якщо я вкажу на вас, синій, ви
скажете, що я можу керувати автомобілем, наприклад, або я
можу їздити  велосипед
так швидко скажи мені речення скажи мені, що
я можу керувати автомобілем або я можу їздити на велосипеді,
добре, зараз давайте потренуємося з я
не можу я не можу літати на літаку, добре, чи я
можу  я не керую автобусом або я не можу керувати
автомобілем, молодець, тому давайте ще
раз
потренуємося добре молодці, давайте рухаємося далі, тож
подивіться, у нас знову три місця, три
групи та засоби транспорту, у нас є
земля, повітря та море, і що  чи можемо ми побачити,
наприклад, на землі на поверхні
nassim li чи можемо ми побачити вертоліт добре,
ви можете, але зазвичай гелікоптер літає
в повітрі, і ви бачите скутер
на морі, гм, тепер ви бачите скутер
на землі,
тому давайте згрупуємося  слова земля повітря і
море я даю вам 10 секунд
запишіть слова
добре готовий перевірити давайте почнемо з
землі, щоб на землі ми могли побачити тренера
начальника автомобіль таксі фургон метро
або метро велосипед мотоцикл скутер а
трамвай і потяг, тому в повітрі ми
бачимо літак і гелікоптер, а на
морі ми бачимо човен і корабель, а тепер
давайте потренуємося з прийменниками,
так що подивіться, ми кажемо на землі,
повторіть, будь ласка, на землі  і швидше
на землі і швидше на землі Браво
з повітрям що  ми говоримо в повітрі, то
давайте підемо в повітрі, і знову в повітрі,
і останній у повітрі, і
третя група див. так додайте море, повторюйте
за мною
додайте море і знову додайте море і
ще раз на  море Браво
зараз давайте потренуємося з реченнями, тому
я бачив транспортні засоби, а ви
користуєтеся поверхнею о, я не бачив, тож
давайте, наприклад, я бачив автобус
на суші, це хороший приклад, або
ви можете сказати, що я притулок  ' не бачив вертольота
в повітрі давайте розглянемо інший приклад
я бачив човен на морі маленьку
дошку але я не бачив вівці в
морі великий корабель давайте йти
я бачив велосипед на землі
але я  я не бачив літак у повітрі,
тож давайте потренуємося з цими реченнями, у
нас зелений і фіолетовий колір, такий зелений,
я бачив фіолетовий, я не бачив, готовий
до тренування, давайте зелений, я
бачив, я бачив таксі на землі  гарний
фіолетовий я не бачив я не
бачив вертольота в повітрі молодець
давайте спробуємо ще раз гарний гарний так і  Останній
раз я бачив скутер на об'єктиві,
і я не бачив скутера на землі.
Браво, дуже дякую,
тому давайте пограємо в гру, а не в
гру, сьогодні ми зі мною пограємо,
щоб ви мені все розповіли  реченнями або
пізніше, ви можете пограти з друзями або
з родиною,
давайте спробуємо переглянути
транспортні засоби, а я збираюся почистити
дошку, тож давайте чотири вузли та хрестики,
нам потрібно дев'ять пробілів, давайте один два
три чотири п'ять шість  допоможіть мені дев'ять хороших
речень, і ми збираємося попрактикуватися в презентаціях ідеальних речень, позитивних негативних
і питання, якщо я попрошу вас скласти
позитивне речення, я бачила машину, о,
вона бачила автомобіль, хороша негативна,
я не бачив машину або  вона не бачила
машину, і питання буде з
тобою
чи ти бачив автомобіль чи вона бачила машину
добре зроблену, і ми будемо використовувати len the
air and the sea, тому допоможіть мені з
прийменником наземний на  земля
наступний з повітрям what was
which прийменник ми використали з повітрям  в
повітрі добре, а потім останній подивіться, що
ми використовуємо з морем, додайте море, тому
давайте вузли і хрести я
буду вузлом, а ти будеш поперек,
тому якщо я хочу поставити свій хрест  тут мені
потрібно сказати позитивне речення,
використовуючи теперішній доконаний час, і сказати
слово на землі, наприклад позитивне
на землі, гм, я бачив скутер
на землі, можливо, можливо, або вона
бачила таксі на землі, це правильно,
тому  ходімо я буду твоїм маркером
сьогодні, тож давайте почнемо, хрести завжди
починаються, і я хочу, щоб ви поставили хрестик,
дайте мені негативне речення з у
повітрі, щоб я не бачив таксі в повітрі
, це правильно, так  ти маєш свій
хрест, тепер моя черга я поставлю
записку тут позитивно з на морі хм, я
бачив вівцю на морі, це
правильно,
зараз я хочу, щоб ти поставив тут хрест,
це буде  питання з
на землі допоможіть мені ви бачили літак
на землі і давайте спробуємо з
питанням інтонації
ви бачили літак на землі
правильно,
хм, я збираюся помістити свою записку тут
позитивно в межах землі, яку вона бачила,
була на землі правильно,
так що ви відразу скажете мені,
Наталія, у нас тут не буде хреста,
давайте  зроби це
позитивно в повітрі. Я впевнений, що
ваш приклад схожий на те, що я
бачив літак у повітрі,
правильно добре, тому давайте помістимо це сюди
мою примітку, так що ви бачили вертоліт
у повітрі добре, і давайте закінчимо з
реченнями так  негатив був на землі
вона не бачила метро на землі добре,
і я збираюся покласти свою записку сюди, так
що ви знову бачили човен на морі
, ви бачили човен на морі і ваш
останній хрест йде  бути тут негативно
з на морі допоможіть мені я не бачив
скутера на морі добре, а це означає,
що ви переможець мої
вітання вам аплодисменти
давайте продовжимо є завдання для
вас подивіться я маю  речення, і вам
потрібно використовувати прислівники частоти, як
часто робити ці речі і  прикметники
в списку для написання речень про
різні види транспорту, перш за все,
давайте подивимося на прикметники
шумний suni зберегти цю сторінку нудну
зі мною стомлююча з Nash Louie дорогий
doraji швидкий ключ зручний багатий
новий дешевий Chevy relaxing Russ lab
лічі повільний Гудіні та небезпечний NAB,
особливо тому різні
транспортні засоби можуть відрізнятися, як тут,
у прикладах, наприклад, я думаю, що подорож
потягом стомлює, тому що ви проводите
багато часу в поїзді або давайте
подивимося ще на один приклад, я часто подорожую
шефом, тому що це дешево, це не
дорого,
тож давайте часто переглядаємо прислівники частоти,
тоді ми зазвичай іноді
ніколи не отримуємо Ніколі завжди субсидію, тому давайте
зосередимося на цьому, давайте зосередимося на дієслові
boring, що може бути нудним для мене, нудно,
це подорожувати тролейбусом, це так
повільно, тож давайте напишемо про це речення,
а ви спочатку використовуєте прислівник частоти,
тому я ніколи не подорожую тролейбусом
я ніколи не подорожую тролейбусом і я
думаю, що це нудно Я думаю, що це нудно
, давайте спробуємо інший приклад
зручно, що може бути зручним для
мене моя машина дуже зручна Мені подобається
подорожувати автомобілем Я завжди подорожую машиною
Я думаю, що це дуже зручно
давайте спробуємо я завжди подорожую машиною Я думаю, що
це  дуже зручно, тому в останньому
прикладі
хм, давайте візьмемо слово повільно, що може бути
повільним, я думаю, скутер або велосипед,
давайте використовувати слово scooter, тому я ніколи не
подорожую скутером, тому що я думаю, що це
дуже повільно, давайте запишемо це,
я ніколи не їздив  скутер
Я думаю, що він повільний, тому ваше домашнє
завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб написати речення, використовуючи
всі прикметники
[Music]
[Music],
і я чую дзвінок, тому,
на жаль, нам потрібно припинити урок,
дуже дякую  і насолоджуйтесь наступною
темою, до побачення
[Музика].